[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und Anne Gellinek
guten Abend manchmal läuft es auch für
Bundeskanzler nicht so wie geplant Olaf
Scholz musste auf seiner Reise nach
Südamerika seinen Gastgeber in Brasilien
erst davon überzeugen dass auf einer
Pressekonferenz Journalisten auch Fragen
stellen können Präsident Lula also ließ
Fragen zu und überraschte dann mit
seinen Antworten auf keinen Fall werde
Brasilien Munition für die Ukraine
liefern schon er könne sein Land
zusammen mit China im Krieg zwischen
Russland und der Ukraine vermitteln über
eine geopolitisch interessante Reise
Blick auf einen brasilianischen
Nationalpark es ist das Ende der
Südamerika Reise von Bundeskanzler
Scholz er wollte einen klima-club ins
Leben rufen Abbau von Rohstoffen und der
Erhalt des Regenwalds und nebenbei
Munition für den geparktpanzer aus
brasilianischen Beständen es kam anders
trotz zunächst erfolgreichen verbens
durch den Kanzler
ich freue mich wir freuen uns alle das
passieren zurück auf der Weltbühne ist
und sich wieder für eine starke
regionale Integration in Lateinamerika
einsetzt ihr habt gefehlt lieber Luna
unüblich Lulas spontaner danken mitten
der Rede des deutschen staatsgasts doch
dann folgten klare Worte des
brasilianischen Präsidenten
Brasilien hatten Entschluss gefasst
keine Munition zu verkaufen weil wir
nicht wünschen dass diese Munition in
diesem Krieg verwendet wird
später gab Lula der Ukraine eine
Teilschuld am Krieg Scholz widersprach
aber wie angespannt die geopolitische
Lage ist zeigt dieses Bild der Kanzler
vergewissert sich bei seinem Berater ob
sein Widerspruch deutlich genug war
Brasilien ist Mitglied der sogenannten
prickstarten kooperiert seit Jahrzehnten
mit Russland Indien und China
wirtschaftlich sie haben teils
geostrategische Interessen mit Russland
gemeint Indien bezieht nicht nur
russisches Öl sondern auch Waffensysteme
aus Moskau
es ist wichtig auf die Geschichte zu
schauen die Beziehungen kommen aus einer
Zeit in der westliche Demokratie in eine
Militärdiktatur in Pakistan
unterstützten und Indien defensivwaffen
verweigerten
China nicht nur in der taiwanfrage über
Kreuz mit den USA macht die Amerikaner
sogar mitverantwortlich für den
ukrainekrieg in Fragen der Ukraine und
der korea-krise hat sich China immer für
politische Lösungen und
Friedensgespräche ausgesprochen war
gegen Worte und Taten die die Konflikte
weiter anheizen
in China Indien Russland auch sie sind
geostrategische Partner Brasiliens
ich schlage vor dass wir eine
friedensgruppe aus Ländern bilden die
versuchen mit Russland und der Ukraine
an einem Tisch zu sitzen um Frieden zu
schaffen dass wir versuchen den Krieg zu
stoppen Brasilien wird sich einbringen
ich habe darüber bereits mit Präsident
macron und auch mit Bundeskanzler Scholz
gesprochen
statt klimaklub eine friedensgruppe es
ist eine neue diplomatische Initiative
die Bundeskanzler Scholz aus Brasilien
mitbringt es wird sich zeigen auf welche
gegen Liebe Lulas Angebote in Moskau und
in Kiew treffen wird
darüber wollen wir reden mit Sebastian
Heilmann er ist Professor für Politik
und Wirtschaft Chinas an der Universität
Trier guten Abend dorthin Herr Heilmann
hat sie die Idee einer brasilianischen
Vermittlung eigentlich überrascht
das hat mich schon überrascht muss ich
sagen weil bis jetzt das eigentlich
nicht auch von chinesischer Seite nicht
thematisiert wurde dass so eine
multinationale Anstrengung unternehmen
unternommen werden soll ich glaube nicht
dass das vorher abgesprochen und
koordiniert war zwischen Brasilien und
China
Bundeskanzler Scholz versucht ja bei
seinen Reisen auch die unentschiedenen
Länder also hier Brasilien auf die
westliche heißt die ukrainische Seite zu
ziehen warum hat das hier in Brasilien
nicht geklappt
es ist so dass viele Entwicklungs- und
Schwellenländer sich da nicht
entscheiden wollen das ist schon ein
großes Misstrauen gegenüber den USA oder
auch gegenüber den Europäern dass die
wieder sozusagen als Kolonialmächte so
ein bisschen die Regeln aufstellen
wollen wir haben momentan die Situation
dass viele Entwicklungs- und
Schwellenländer selbst wenn sie
Demokratien sind nicht
selbstverständlich auf die Position von
den Europäern und Amerikanern
einschwenken das ist schon auch ein
Statement für eine eigene unabhängige
Außenpolitik was dort gegeben wurde was
sind denn Chinas Interessen in diesem
Konflikt sie haben das mal als Eiertanz
bezeichnet
nach China hat zunächst mal das
Interesse dass Russland im Grunde die
Schwäche des Westens zeigt dass also der
Ukraine Krieg so verläuft dass die
Schwäche der USA und das
nato-bündnissystems der offengelegt wird
das war das Interesse Chinas das hat
jetzt nicht geklappt weil sich das
hinzieht aber es ist klar dass China das
geostrategische Interesse hat mit
Russland sozusagen diese Macht der USA
und us-bundes Systems einzudämmen das
ist ganz klar das gemeinsame
geopolitische und geostrategische
Interesse zwischen Moskau und Peking
aber schade dieser Krieg nicht auch
Chinas wirtschaftlichen Interessen es
kann doch nicht sein dass China sich
wirklich auf Handel mit Russland da
versteifen will
das ist ganz richtig das also natürlich
weiterhin diese Märkte im besten für
China unglaublich wichtig sind zugleich
China aber wirklich dabei ist in den
Schwellenländern in den
Entwicklungsländern des globalen Südens
eine eigene wirtschaftliche Hemisphäre
aufzubauen und dass das neue was wir oft
übersehen wird in der westlichen Welt
dass China sich sehr stark ausrichtet
eine neue ausrichtet auf neue Märkte in
Entwicklungs-
der wichtigste Handelspartner für die
meisten Länder auch in Lateinamerika und
der wichtigste Investor und das zeigt
sich inzwischen eben auch dass China
unverzichtbar ist wenn 30 Prozent der
Exporte von Brasilien nach China gehen
dann ist das sozusagen eine überragende
macht die präsent ist in Lateinamerika
und das wird auf dem besten noch
übersehen wie weit China schon gedient
ist dabei globalen Süden eigene
wirtschaftliche Hemisphäre aufzubauen
im Moment sind ja Verhandlungen zwischen
Russland und der Ukraine überhaupt nicht
wahrscheinlich aber wenn es welche gäbe
gesetzt den Fall hätte eine chinesische
Vermittlung Chancen würde das Sinn
machen
china hat sich sehr zurückgehalten was
das angeht sie haben im Grunde nur eine
rote Linie gezogen bei dem Einsatz von
Nuklearwaffen da hat Peking klar gesagt
das ist das nicht mittragen wird in
keiner Form aber Peking hat keinerlei
mäßigende Wirkung auf Russland ausgeübt
das beispielsweise die die den Anti
Angriffe auf zivile Ziele in der Ukraine
angeht verständlich jetzt letzten
Monaten das Thema China weiß das auch
hat er nicht eingeschnitten auch nichts
Kritisches gesagt dass ich bin sehr
skeptisch ob Peking da wirklich jetzt
eine mäßigende aktive Rolle gegenüber
Russland spielen kann das sieht momentan
nicht danach aus sagt Sebastian Heilmann
China-Experte und Professor an der
Universität Trier herzlichen Dank
dorthin
das Gespräch haben wir vor einer Stunde
aufgezeichnet in der Ukraine wird
unterdessen weiter gekämpft im Gebiet
dann jetzt im Osten der Ukraine haben
die russischen Truppen nach eigenen
Angaben das Dorf blahodne erobert die
Stadt krematorsk liegt rund 30 km
westlich und befindet sich weiterhin
unter Kontrolle der Ukraine die Menschen
die dort leben fürchten sich angesichts
der näherrückenden Kämpfe und bleiben
doch dort weil sie nicht anders können
unsere Reporterin Katrin Eigendorf war
in grammatosk
der Weg nach krematorsk führt durch ein
zerstörtes Land nichts ist hier
geblieben die Häuser unbewohnbar
verlassen
auf dem kleinen Wochenmarkt von
kremators ist Angst und Sorge spürbar
die heftig umkämpfte Stadt bachmut ist
nur 35 km entfernt von hier
das ist ganz bei uns in der Nähe noch
ein bisschen und dann ist das alles bei
uns deshalb besorgt uns diese Situation
sehr
du legst dich schlafen mit Angst du
wachst damit auf ohne Ende Angriffe das
alles macht Angst
von 1,210000 Einwohner sind 70.000
geblieben es sind vor allem die älteren
und die Armen die nicht gehen können
oder nicht gehen wollen in einem
Luftschutzkeller treffen wir Alexander
und scharenko der Bürgermeister von
kremators spricht deutsch mit Schweizer
Akzent er hat in Bern studiert es ist
kalt im Keller Heizungen Strom fallen
ständig aus immer wieder musste auch der
Bürgermeister bei Angriffen im Feldbett
übernachten was ist seine größte Sorge
neben den Angriffen
sollte wochenweise Wochen war dann wird
es schwierig leben also das heißt die
zentrale Heizung fällt sofort auf also
man kann zwei drei Tage das kann man
schon
heizen aber länger dauert es nicht auf
dem plottert Mira dem Platz des Friedens
wirkt krematorsk wie eine Geisterstadt
verlassene Geschäfte verlassene Straßen
Gräben sollen Schutz bieten bei
Luftangriffen auch an diesem Morgen
schrillen die Sirenen nur wenig wurde
zerstört in krematorsk in den elf
Monaten Krieg die russische Armee konnte
bislang hierhin nicht vordringen doch am
Bahnhof erinnert ein Mann mal an einen
der brutalsten Angriffe die Stofftiere
gehörten den sieben Kindern die hier am
8 April von russischen Raketen getötet
wurden als sie mit ihren Familien auf
den evakuierungszug warteten der sie in
Sicherheit bringen sollte
haben sie noch Beziehungen zu Russland
keine einzige keine einzige mehr alle
Telefonate alle Kontakte gelöscht wann
noch im Vorjahr das war schon im März
Vorjahres
keine Schulfreunde keine Verwandte mehr
alles Vergangenheit
die Zukunft davon ist der Bürgermeister
von kremators überzeugt kann nur in
einem Sieg über Russland liegen mit
Hilfe des Westens
und hier geht es weiter mit den
Nachrichten und Gundula und der Reise
des amerikanischen Außenministers in den
Nahen Osten vor dem Hintergrund der
jüngsten schweren Gewalt zwischen Israel
und den Palästinensern hat
US-Außenminister blinken erneut beide
Seiten zu Mäßigung aufgerufen bei seinem
Besuch in ramala setzte er sich
gegenüber Palästinenser Präsident Abbas
für ein Festhalten an der zwei
staatenlösung ein aber es machte Israel
für die jüngste Eskalation
verantwortlich im Januar starben 35
Palästinenser bei Zusammenstößen mit der
israelischen Armee daraufhin tötete ein
Palästinenser sieben Israelis in
Jerusalem
in Frankreich hat ein zweiter
landesweiter Generalstreik gegen die
geplante Rentenreform das öffentliche
Leben zum zum großen Teil lahmgelegt dem
Aufruf der Gewerkschaften folgten
landesweit hunderttausende aber nicht so
viele wie am ersten Protesttag vor
eineinhalb Wochen die Streikenden lehnen
die geplante Anhebung des
Renteneintrittsalters von 62 auf 64
Jahre ab Präsident macron will dagegen
die Reform unbedingt durchsetzen um das
Rentensystem zu retten
als einziges Bundesland hat Bayern die
Abgabefrist für die grundsteuererklärung
um weitere drei Monate verlängert
nachdem Bund und Länder zuvor bereits
einen Aufschub um drei Monate gewährt
hatten müssen Millionen Eigentümer also
bis heute ihre Erklärungen abgegeben
haben laut Bundesfinanzministerium
fehlten gestern noch etwa 30 Prozent für
fast 36 Millionen Grundstücke muss die
Steuer neu berechnet werden
Bundeswirtschaftsminister Habeck fordert
einen zügigeren Ausbau von Windanlagen
auch auf See davon profitierten auch die
deutschen Produktionsstätten beim Besuch
eines turbinenwerkes in Cuxhaven
erklärte Harbeck bis 2030 solle die
Windenergie auf See von derzeit gut acht
auf 30 GB erhöht werden dieses Ziel sei
so der grünen Politiker schaffbar
noch aber reichen die erneuerbaren
Energien nicht aus um Deutschland zu
versorgen und da kommt Niedersachsen ins
Spiel hier gibt es nämlich zwei
umstrittene Erdgasfelder die zwar
bewilligt sind aber zur Zeit nicht
genutzt werden solange das prom aus
Russland lieferte war es zu teuer
deutsches Gas aus rund 5000 Metern Tiefe
zu fördern jetzt aber will einen
kanadisches Unternehmen die Felder
wisselhorst und Osterheide Ausbeuten
ganz ohne Fracking
Ärger gibt es trotzdem Peter Kunst
berichtet
Gas für Deutschland aus Deutschland hier
in der niedersächsischen Heide wären sie
sich dagegen wollen nicht das wieder
aufgebohrt wird was jahrelang still lag
weil Förderung am Bohrloch wisselshorst
sich nicht lohnte russisches billiggas
hatte die Preise kaputt gemacht jetzt
aber leben wir in einer anderen Welt und
eine kanadische Firma will den Profit
aus dem Boden holen vielen Anwohnern
macht das sorgen die Gründe sind eben
dass wir hier schlechtes Erdgas haben
das sogenannte el-gas logas was
gereinigt werden muss wo Benzol
Quecksilber sehen und alle möglichen
Chemikalien drin sind
Krebsrisiko Gefahren für Luft und
Trinkwasser mögliche Erdbeben die Ängste
der Burg Gegner
in Niedersachsen wissen die Menschen das
Energie selten zum Umwelt Nulltarif zu
haben ist vor 60 Jahren setzte hier mit
erfolgreichen Probebohrungen der
deutsche gasboum ein die Vorkommen
hierzulande finden sich fast
ausschließlich in Niedersachsen heute
werden in Deutschland noch rund 5
Milliarden Kubikmeter Erdgas im Jahr
gefördert ein Viertel von dem was aus
heimischen Boden kam bevor wir uns an
die russische Pipeline hängten wie an
einen Tropf neues deutsches Gas ist eine
verfügbare Alternative in
homöopathischen Mengen die Bohrung
wissels Horst erklärt der kanadische
Konzern beim Bürgerdialog kann 100.000
Haushalte versorgen und spart zwei
flüssig erdgasschiffe im Jahr
hier in Deutschland wird unter sehr
strengen Auflagen werden Bohrungen
abgetäuscht und das Erdgas auch
produziert und das ist nicht nur unsere
Firmenphilosophie sondern eben auch
unsere stringente genehmigungswelt sage
ich jetzt mal grundsätzlich was
Gesundheitsschädigung angeht oder dieser
Vorwurf sage ich mal oder dieses diese
Sorge konnte glaube ich über vielerlei
Studien entkräftet werden und wie sieht
das Ganze jetzt in das Gasfeld dass die
Firma the Million anzapfen will liegt
fast 5000 m tief und reist einen Boden
Spalt in die neue rot-grüne Koalition in
Niedersachsen wann ist Schluss mit
fossiler Energie wir haben rechtlich
nicht die Möglichkeit aus Klimaschutz
Gründen Öl und Gasförderung zu stoppen
das kann nur der Bund wo erwarten vom
Bund dass er sich auch mit seinen
Klimazielen den Länder die Möglichkeit
gibt Förderung zum Beispiel an den
Klimazielen ähm orientiert zu stoppen
wir wissen auch dass wir auf Gas eben in
einer Übergangszeit angewiesen sind also
unter den Sicherheitsvoraussetzungen die
wir auch festlegen oder festlegen müssen
sind wir aus meiner Sicht auch in der
Lage sicherzustellen dass
Erdgasförderung möglich ist und auch
gesichert möglich ist der Bürgerdialog
der Bohrfirma in der niedersächsischen
Heide hat die Zweifel der Gegner nicht
ausgeräumt aber sie werden wohl nicht
verhindern können dass ab Ende 2024
neues heimisches Gas gefördert wird
alles damit Deutschland warm bleibt
der Fachkräftemangel in Deutschland
bleibt ein Riesenproblem Unternehmen
melden
764.000 offene Stellen und er betrifft
vor allem Firmen der sogenannten
MINT-Berufe also Mathe Informatik
Naturwissenschaft und Technik ein
Bereich in dem nur jede fünfte
Mitarbeiterin eine Frau ist dabei sind
mintberufe gut bezahlt trotzdem fühlen
sich Frauen in diesen Jobs immer noch
als halbe Aliens wie es eine Tech
Managerin beschreibt und deutschland
schneidet im EU-Durchschnitt besonders
schlecht ab Peter Böhmer über Gründe und
Auswege
Elektrotechnik Vorlesung an der RWTH
Aachen einer Kaderschmiede für den
technischen Nachwuchs 200 erste Meister
sind da die männlichen Studierenden
klein der Mehrzahl nur knapp 20% sind
Frauen in Maschinenbau oder Informatik
sieht es ähnlich aus und klar ist wer
als Frau etwas Technisches studiert hat
mit Klischees zu kämpfen
von erwachsenen Männern würde ich sagen
die gucken ein bisschen auf einen runter
und denken sich was will die hier vor
allem wenn man so aussieht wie ich sage
jetzt mal er geschminkt und so da merkt
man noch so ein bisschen Sexismus das
wird dann direkt gesagt oh wow wie toll
dass du dich das traust und dann finde
ich dieses trauen einfach oft so ein
bisschen komisch weil ich denke ich
mache das worauf ich Lust habe ich habe
auch selber teilweise sehr selten aber
das kann man leider auch schon vor das
Gefühl bekommen dass ich das ähm weniger
kann oder man hat mir gezeigt dass ich
das weniger kann und das ist so
unterschwellig so ein bisschen
durchkommen weil ich eine Frau bin
eigentlich liegt Deutschland in der EU
bei den MINT-Fächern ganz vorne 36%
aller Studierenden machten 2020 daran
einen Bachelorabschluss doch der
Frauenanteil betrug hier zu lange nur
22% in Griechenland oder Schweden lag er
deutlich höher
es gibt in unserer Gesellschaft
althergebrachte Rollenerwartungen und
damit auch Einstellungen darüber was man
eher als männerfächer oder frauenfächer
versteht da geht es dann um das
persönliche Umfeld aber vielleicht auch
um die Einstellung der Betroffenen
selbst die sich vielleicht ein bindfach
dann auch nicht unbedingt zutrauen wie
kann man das ändern die Aachener etwa
bieten schnupper-uni oder Labortage für
Schülerinnen an und setzen auf neue
Zielgruppen das Potenzial sich
insbesondere bei der Generation
freiheits for future wir müssen einfach
klar machen dass z.B Maschinenbau
eigentlich nichts mit Schmieröl zu tun
hat sondern dass der Maschinenbau
Hochtechnologie ist dass ich damit die
anstehenden Probleme dieser Welt lösen
kann die Hochschule von Mülheim an der
Ruhr hat einen anderen Ansatz einen
Maschinenbau Studienzweig nur für Frauen
in den ersten vier Semestern
das ist so immer noch in den Köpfen drin
ich möchte nicht die einzige Frau unter
100 Männern im Hörsaal sein und dann
quasi wie so ein bunter Hund auffallen
und das ist für einige so ein
Abschreckung dass Sie sich dagegen
entscheiden und wir wollten einfach mal
einen anderen Zugang geben das ist schön
am Anfang wenn man in diesem Materie
einsteigt dass man sich nicht eben noch
dafür verteidigen muss dass man
überhaupt Maschinenbau macht sondern
dass man angenommen wird dass man ja
jede Frau kann Maschinenbau machen und
das wenn man eben mit Fragen zusammen
studiert man muss sich nicht mit den
Ellenbogen durchwachsen sie konnten in
Mülheim die Zahl der Studentinnen
verdoppeln Industrie Arbeitgeber wie der
Motorenhersteller Deutz aus Köln hören
das gerne brauchen dringend Fachkräfte
würden es aber noch mehr begrüßen wenn
es unabhängig vom Geschlecht mehr
Absolventen gäbe der Frauenanteil an
sich hat erstmal für uns glaube ich
keine Bedeutung wichtig ist dass die
Anzahl an Leuten die aus diesen
Studiengängen rauskommen erhöht wird
wenn das mehr Frauen werden würden wir
das sehr begrüßen es muss sich etwas
bewegen bei den Universitäten nicht nur
um Frauen voranzubringen
und den gesamten Arbeitsmarkt mit den
aktuellen Zahlen hat Gundula im Blick in
den Nachrichten trotz aller
geopolitischen und wirtschaftlichen
Unsicherheiten der Arbeitsmarkt in
Deutschland ist stabil ins neue Jahr
gestartet im Januar registrierte die
Bundesagentur für Arbeit zwei Millionen
616.000 Arbeitslose
162.000 mehr als im Dezember und
154.000 mehr als vor einem Jahr die
Quote stieg auf 5,7%
finanzielle Unterstützung in der Krise
leistet auch die staatliche Förderbank
KfW und das im vergangenen Jahr in einer
rekorddimension die noch über dem
Volumen des corona-jahres 2020 liegt
Valerie Haller da geht es um einen
dreistelligen Milliardenbetrag wie
schafft die Kaffee das na nach eigenen
Angaben hat sie ihre Grenzen nicht
getestet räumt aber ein dass dies ein
Ausnahmejahr war
167 Milliarden Euro hat die KfW 2022
verteilt doppelt so viel wie
normalerweise ein besonderes Jahr ja
aber in der Vergangenheit musste die KfW
immer wieder mit Rettungsmilliarden
einspringen und das macht sie inzwischen
zum drittgrößten Kreditinstitut der
Republik 2022 war sie vorwiegend damit
beschäftigt die Folgen des Ukraine
Kriegs abzufedern größter Posten die
Sicherstellung der Energieversorgung
darunter die Rettung des gashändlers
Juniper zweitgrößter posten die
energieeffizien für Gebäude dieses Jahr
plant die Förderbank möglichst andere
Schwerpunkte zu setzen im Zentrum stehen
Themen wie Klimaschutz und
Digitalisierung die KfW feiert 75 Jahre
ihres Bestehens und musste doch auch
einige Pannen verkraften stimmt legendär
ist die Geschichte als die KfW am Tag
des Insolvenzantrags von Limon Brothers
noch 320 Millionen Euro an die
Investmentbank überwie ist das trug ihr
bei der Bild den Titel Deutschlands
dümmste Bank ein sowas geht ja auch auf
Kosten des Steuerzahlers aber alles in
allem ist die KfW schon lange wichtige
Anlaufstelle für Mittelständler Häusle
Bauer und studieren die durch sie an
günstige Kredite kommen sie unterstützt
auch Entwicklungsländer und Start-ups
ist eine gefragte Krisenfeuerwehr und
das wird sie wohl auch erstmal bleiben
vielen Dank Valerie nach Frankfurt
die erneuten Wahlen zum Berliner
Abgeordnetenhaus sowie die Bezirkswahlen
können wie geplant am 12 februar
stattfinden das Bundesverfassungsgericht
hat eine Verschiebung der Wahlen
abgelehnt die genaue Prüfung ob die
komplette Wiederholung der pannenwahl
vom September 2021 verfassungsgemäß ist
wird allerdings erst im Nachhinein
erfolgen die mehr als 40 Kläger
kritisieren die Wiederholung als zu
weitgehend Wahlleitung und viele
Politiker in Berlin reagierten
erleichtert
seit zehn Jahren erzieht Deutschland bei
der Bekämpfung von Korruption in Politik
und Verwaltung keine Fortschritte das
belegt die Organisation transparent sie
international in ihrem aktuellen
Korruptionsindex der insgesamt 180
Länder auflistet Deutschland ist da auf
Platz 9 am besten schneidet Dänemark ab
auf dem letzten Platz Somalia Ziele
versuchte Einflussnahme über Korruption
sein vor allem in Europa und in
Deutschland
für Papst franziskus ist diese seine
fünfte Afrika-Reise eine Pilgerfahrt des
Friedens im Südsudan und der
Demokratischen Republik Kongo will er
vergessene Konflikte in Erinnerung
bringen
hunderttausende jubelten bei seiner
Ankunft in Kinshasa zu im
Präsidentenpalast prangerte er die
ausländische Ausbeutung der Bodenschätze
im Kongo an ebenso wie die andauernde
Gewalt durch rivalisierende
Rebellengruppen im Kongo leben rund 50
Millionen Christen eine der größten
katholischen Gruppen Afrikas
es können Momente für die Ewigkeit sein
vor allem wenn ein kleiner gegen einen
großen siegt das ist der besondere Reiz
beim DFB-Pokal denn nun in seiner
entscheidende Phase eintritt das
Achtelfinale der Kleine ist in diesem
Fall der Zweitligist SC Paderborn der
große der VfB Stuttgart aus der ersten
Liga einen Gewinner muss es geben Jan
döhling weiß wer es ist
Lukas krasniok und der kleine SC
Paderborn gegen Labbadia Stuttgarter
aber wer ist hier groß und wer klein der
VfB in der Bundesliga ein Abstiegsnot
auch heute geht's bescheiden los führte
Minute macropanos trifft aber es ist das
falsche Tor nämlich das eigene das erste
Profi Eigentor des Stuttgarters er wird
getröstet es ist ein Treffer passend zur
Situation der Schwaben der Zweitligist
führt Stuttgart rennt an vom Tor ist
sein Offenbarungseid dieser Freistoß von
Gassi noch die beste Chance Labbadia da
steht ein Trainer auch Sinnbild kräftig
im Regen die zweite Halbzeit und mal ein
kleiner Aufreger im Paderborner
Strafraum Verteidiger Rohr bekommt den
Ball zwar an den Arm aber der
Schiedsrichter lässt weiterlaufen
absolut korrekt 70 Minute Paderborn
macht offensiv wenig jetzt doch mal die
konter-chance conté auf leiperts der
sieht auf der anderen Seite Felix Platte
der zielt zu ungenau der VfB stand jetzt
erst ein Schuss aufs Tor 76 minute auch
dieser Ball geht vorbei die rasiert es
ist die beste Chance aber noch ist das
Spiel nicht vorbei in der 86 Minute Gel
Dias am Bike gestern verpflichtet von
Benfica Lissabon und das nennt man einen
Einstand nach Maß plötzlich riecht nach
Verlängerungen Ostwestfalen die hat sich
der VfB redlich verdient letzter Aktion
des Spiels 17 der Ecke VfB Stenzel auf
dieser See der Pokal er schreibt die
verrückten Geschichten die dass sie Kopf
Stuttgart
Viertelfinale
das möchte ich aber Rauschen das für
mich jetzt kein glücklicher Sieg war um
17:0 Ecken gehabt wir haben mal 25 zu 1
Torschüsse gehabt
am drei Tore gemacht heute am Platz das
entscheidende die rassie der Kopf groß
schlägt also klein der Zweitligist ist
raus
und alle Tore alles entscheidende vom
zweiten Pokalspiel des Abends Union
Berlin gegen den VfL Wolfsburg sehen Sie
bei uns gegen Mitternacht im heute
journal Update
und das mit wulfschmiese wir wünschen
einen angenehmen Abend danke für Ihr
Interesse bis morgen tschüss
[Musik]
guten Abend wir befinden uns im Moment
in einer strammen nordwestströmung und
das sorgt für nasskalt und stürmisches
Wetter morgen gibt es verbreitet
Spitzenböen um 70 80 an der Nordseeküste
in höheren Lagen oder auch in schauen
und Gewittern sogar mit 100 km pro
Stunde schon heute Nacht bleibt der Wind
lebhaft es gibt restschauer im südlichen
Bergland im Norden verstärkt sich die
Schauertätigkeit wieder auch mit
einzelnen Gewittern bei 0 bis 5 Grad
leichtfröstlich nur im Bergland bis
minus zwei Grad morgen erreichen wir
drei Grad an den Alpen 9 Grad am
Niederrhein und es ist ungemütlich immer
wieder ziehen von Nordwest nach
südostschauer durch auch mal mit
graupeln und Gewittern am meisten fällt
nachmittags in Nordwesten am wenigsten
im Südwesten dazu dieser schneiden kalte
Wind der auch für Schneeverwehungen
sorgen kann es fällt zwar nicht ganz so
viel aber im Harz und den östlichen
Mittelgebirgen ist das schon etwas mehr
und Schnee und Schneeverwehungen sind
auch in den nächsten Tagen ein Thema und
zwar in den Alpen bis Freitag Abend kann
oberhalb von 1000 Meter 30 cm bis ein
Meter Schnee zusammenkommen und das bei
stürmischen Verhältnissen am Freitag
erst am Wochenende wird es wieder etwas
ruhiger und wir schauen jetzt noch
schnell ins All
denn am Nachthimmel können Sie die
nächsten Tage den Kometen C 2022 E3
entdecken er ist circa einen Kilometer
breit und besteht aus Staubteilchen
Gasen und Eis durch die Annäherung an
die Sonne verdampfen Teile des Eises
neuer Staub und Gase werden freigesetzt
und ein riesige teilchenhülle entsteht
Durchmesser 50.000 km so grünlich
schimmert sie durch jede Menge
Kohlenstoff von der Erde aus nehmen wir
diese teilchenhöhle als leuchtenden
Schweif war morgen kommt uns der Komet
am nächsten und bei klarem Himmel ist er
nahe des kleinen Wagens zu sehen viel
Glück beim Suchen und einen schönen
Abend